the president tested positive for the
coronavirus late last week since then
his public events have been canceled
he's not participated in any interviews
on camera
now the president's physician says he
has completed his course of therapy for
the virus and can return to public
engagements as soon as tomorrow
by any measure it's been a remarkable
turnaround
on saturday we were hearing rumors that
the president was very sick
on monday he seemed essentially himself
how'd that happen well to learn more
about the process
of the president's recovery our own dr
mark siegel spoke to donald trump today
it was as we said his first time talking
on camera about what happened
we should know that these are very
unusual circumstances normally we'd send
our own camera crew
into the white house to interview the
president but because his diagnosis was
just a week ago
we had to rely on the white house camera
team for that interview
dr siegel interviewed the president from
new york here it is
president trump welcome uh this is not
officially a television though as you
probably realize i've done hundreds
but i hope you'll indulge me and let you
be the patient
and i'll be the doctor here and i
promise you no co-pay
okay okay sounds sounds good to me mark
so
the first question is what we call the
chief complaint which is
briefly how are you feeling now i feel
really good i feel very strong
i know a lot of people that have had the
covid or the china virus as i call it
because it came from china
but i feel really really strong and a
lot of people
don't feel that way sometimes for a
while afterwards but
very good what about symptoms that you
had
last friday like when you went into
walter reed what were the two most
prominent symptoms that
you had i think didn't feel strong
didn't feel really strong i didn't have
a problem with breathing
which a lot of people seemed to have i
had none of that
but i didn't feel very strong i didn't
feel very vital
i didn't feel like the president of the
u.s should feel
and i knew there was something a little
bit off and the doctors at walter reed
were incredible they came from johns
hopkins they came from everywhere it's
good to be president i guess but
they were really great people but i
would say more weakness than anything
else mark
you know mr president i got to tell you
something confidentially my patients
never listen to me
no matter how hard i try they don't do
what i say half the time
did that occur to you where the doctors
were telling you something and you were
negotiating with them or did you just do
what they said
i did negotiate but you know ultimately
i have a lot of respect for these
doctors
they're really the best doctors i think
in the world and
walter reed i've seen the work they do
on the military and
people coming in so badly injured that
like you've never seen before i have a
lot of respect so
i really tended to listen but generally
maybe i wouldn't but i would i did tend
to listen to this group
when you were in the hospital what was
bothering you the most what
were you feeling i i just think that uh
it was just you were tired you were
you know was just getting to you from
the standpoint you didn't have that same
energy level
and you know my life is based a little
bit on energy and you didn't have it
and uh i don't know you know it could
have led to bad things from that point i
don't know but i i got
lucky i think with a certain medicine
but uh
it really it really was something i took
a certain medicine that was
you know very miraculous to me i think i
really don't believe it's just in the
head either i think it's
i really believe it worked were you
scared were you frightened
well i took the regeneron and eli lilly
makes a similar very similar medicine
but you have regenerate you have the eli
lilly version of it and it just
within a period of 24 hours i felt very
different i think i could have left the
hospital a lot earlier
but it made a tremendous difference mark
and uh
you know markedly so and and uh i just
felt very good
it it uh you would have sort of a sore
throat
just to add to what we were saying but
but i felt
really very very good after taking this
for
a period of time it's a transfusion not
a shot
and uh you know i i'd like to send it to
everybody in fact i've said i'm going to
send it to everybody
that's got the problem and we're going
to send it free of charge
including seniors of course but uh we're
going to send it to everybody
did you want to leave earlier the
hospital earlier than they said
i did president they wanted to keep me
for observation you know they wanted to
be sure it was good but
i did i was there for i guess three and
a half days they wanted to keep me
uh i wanted to leave after the first day
i really felt i was in
not bad shape after the first day i
think i would have been in much worse
shape had i not taken this uh
medication how long did they want to
keep you the doctors
i i don't know exactly but they they
kept me for the time i stayed for the
time that they needed me
and they've done a lot of tests they've
done tremendous testing
and uh right now i'm uh medication free
i'm not taking any medications as of
you know probably eight hours ago or so
i'm medication free
which frankly makes me feel good i don't
like medication
mr president if you would feel
comfortable can you tell me a little bit
about the tests you had in the hospital
did you have a cat scan what did that
show
yeah they tested the lungs they have
incredible equipment at
walter reed in fact uh
they said no you could leave your jacket
on that's the first that's ever happened
leave your shirt on leave your jacket on
i said i'll take it off anyway if you
want
but literally they tested the lungs they
checked for the lungs and they tested it
with different machinery they have
incredible stuff that i've never even
seen before
and it tested it tested good initially i
think they had some congestion in there
but it tested ultimately it tested good
and with each day it got better and i
think that's why they wanted me to stay
frankly but the cat scans were amazing
the equipment was incredible i've never
seen equipment like this before
well we learned this afternoon the next
presidential debate which had been
scheduled for october 15th next week has
now been canceled dr siegel spoke with
the president
about the issues surrounding that debate
just before the news broke that it won't
happen at all
he also asked the president about his
car ride outside walter reed the one the
media told you
endangered his staff it's interesting
here's more of dr siegel's interview
with the president
could you talk to me about when you went
outside uh walter reed and ppe
and the drive that you took and and well
wishers and and what you were thinking
when you did that
well i had tremendous numbers of people
i could hear them from the hospital and
i was way up high and you know this very
fortified
military hospital that's you know built
to the highest standard and yet
through these very powerful windows i
could hear people screaming and shouting
and with love
with real love and after two days i said
you know i want to go out and say hello
to the people and i went to secret
service and these are the people that
are with me all the time
and they said we have no problem sir i
said i just want to take a drive
by them and just wave and you saw what
happened it was a great display of love
out there
it's i i don't think there was one
negative person
and there were many many many people but
i don't think there was anybody negative
out there it was just
they were they went crazy when they saw
the van go by the you know the the car
go by
and the people in were protected they
were very heavily protected
uh because at that time i guess i would
have been positive
uh but they were very very protected
and they've been with me you know
they've they been with me for a long
time
and they understand but they also
thought it was very important i thought
it was very important to show my
affection
for them they were standing out there 24
hours a day you saw that i mean every
time you
you'd be on television you see them in
the background and i just thought i
you know i love the people that i love
the people of this country
and i thought it would have been very
disrespectful if i was there for three
three and a half days and
these people are there standing late at
night early in the morning and
i didn't go out and at least give them a
little wave
and that's what i did and i'm very glad
i did it
mr president lessons learned from this
from your own illness
that you would apply to the to the ship
to
to stewarding the ship forward in the
fight in the pandemic
and what and how you can apply it to
other people that have covet 19 and how
to prevent getting covert 19
lessons learned it's such a great
question i think the biggest thing is
that i did do it early
now you know i have such great access to
medical we have white house doctor who's
great and you have so many great doctors
so it's a lot easier for me than
somebody that's
you know not doesn't have access to a
doctor so easily where it's a big deal
to see a doctor but
you know here we have them all over the
white house frankly they're watching
every corner
but i think very important for me was
very early i you know as soon as i felt
something
and you know and i'm thinking about it
because i see what's going on and i have
a lot of a lot of people are around me
even though there's tremendous testing
but a lot of people are around me so i
think about it
and i know there's a danger but i can't
be somebody that goes into a basement
and just hides in a basement for the
rest of my life i'm
i'm running a country the greatest
country in the world
so what uh what i think the big secret
for me was i got there very early
and uh you know i think it would have
gotten a lot worse
one of the doctors said he thought it
would have gotten a lot worse
i just think that even these medications
they're a lot better if you get them
early than if you get them late you know
it will react probably better
so i think going in early is a big
factor in my case dexamethasone i've
given it to a lot of patients i've given
steroids to a lot of patients they've
many most have tolerated it well
sometimes there's issues with anxiety or
behavioral issues did you have any
problem with that
no i didn't even know i had it i didn't
know what it was it's a form of a
steroid but it keeps the swelling down
of the lungs as i understand it
and uh i i tolerated it very well i i
don't take it anymore but it was uh
pretty short term during during the
course of the medicine that was one of
the medicines
and no i think i tolerated it very well
mark and and uh
it keeps the swelling down and that's
important
what are you taking right now as of
today i think really nothing
uh we pretty much finished
and now we'll see how things go but
pretty much nothing
we had our final doses of just about
everything actually the tr the original
transfusion
that's supposed to last for about four
months you know that uh the antibodies
and i think you're supposed to be
protected anywhere from two to four
months and maybe longer than that i
don't know are you going to donate your
own plasma mr president
well i will nobody's asked me that
question actually but i will
uh if that's if they want me to do it
i'd love to do it
are you tested i heard you i heard you
said you were going to test again today
have you been retested
i have been retested and i haven't even
found out numbers or anything yet but
i've been retested
and i know i'm at either the bottom of
the scale or free
when is your next test going to be i
don't know probably tomorrow mark they
test
every couple of days i guess but uh it's
really at a level now that's been
uh great great to see it disappear so
i have a question and this is my own
fantasy mr president
all of this back and forth controversy
about the next debate
and if you test negative uh and you've
said you want it to be in person
how would you feel about a debate
outside on miami beach
well i'd have no trouble with it at all
in fact when we have rallies outside
we've had no problem whatsoever outside
is better than inside as you know with
this crazy thing that's gone on
but i would have no problem with it but
you know we have a
we've always had a problem with this
commission this commission's been
ridiculous frankly but
who wants to do a debate on a computer i
don't
uh you know virtual debate no you got to
be you got to be there we
we did great on the last debate you have
to be there you have to see the person
you can't do it on a computer besides
that you know joe has a tendency to get
the answers and read them off a computer
for
when he's asked questions so i'd rather
i would love to do it
outside would be fine as far as i'm
concerned where do you think you got the
virus at what point do you think you
contracted it looking back
you know i don't know they had some big
events at the white house
and uh uh perhaps there
i don't really know nobody really knows
for sure
numerous people have contracted it but
you know people have contracted it all
over the world it's highly contagious
that's one thing you learn this is a
contagious
disease and generally you get better
from it but
we also now have medicines that will
help a lot
and if you look at mortality rate i
think it's up uh
95 or 85 percent mark i think you've
seen that you pointed it out to me
uh what we're doing now with the
medicines and
all of the things is incredible but uh
you know especially younger people you
look i wish they'd open schools i hope
they open schools some of the states are
closed and
the cure is worse than the problem
itself in many cases it's a terrible
thing
mr president a final message from you to
america
about what they can learn from your
illness and your recovery which
many would say is inspiring a final
message
i just have such great respect for the
doctors and
labs scientists the people that work on
this they're doing incredibly well i
have
uh incredible respect and love for the
families that have suffered so badly
this is something that came to us out of
i don't know i won't be able to tell you
yet maybe at some point i'll be able to
report exactly why it came to us but it
came out of china it shouldn't have
happened
they should have never let it happen but
they suffered plenty also far more than
people understand
but this is something that should not
have been allowed to they should not
have allowed this to come out to the
world not only to the united states to
the world
but i have such respect for the people
that have suffered
and my sympathies to those families that
have been so horribly hurt
and and just horribly hurt and
uh again the respect for the doctors
and for the technicians and for the
scientists is incredible
because i've seen what they've done and
it's incredible the
the the job that they've done in a short
period of time
over a six-month period the job that
they've done is incredible
and you'll see that very soon with the
medicines and with the
vaccines mr president i i really
appreciate that last answer
and the interview and i want to tell you
how much it means to us that you
appeared for your first on-camera
interview tonight
on tucker carlson tonight thank you so
much for joining me well thank you very
much mark
it's my great honor thank you